well new at four o'clock we are seeing
dramatic body camera video as a metro
police officer shoots and kills a man
now that man was armed with a knife and
had just killed his wife the 8 news now
i-team's david charns is live this
afternoon at metro headquarters where
they just wrapped up a news conference
about this investigation david
christian police say they entered this
home after getting a call from a family
member saying that this man had just
stabbed and killed his wife the officers
entered the home and they go to a very
small bedroom that is when they say in
the video shows that this man
lunged at the officers we do want to
warn you that this video is quite
graphic
police identifying the man as 48 year
old 46 year old brother miguel gallarzo
he lived in that home with his wife
delia luna rojo metro saying this was an
argument that simply spun out of control
and the insistent sheriff reminding
everybody that there is help out there
it's difficult
i was there
and seeing something like that and the
effects that it has on families is
difficult
for all of us as i said at the beginning
it's important for us to reach out to
the community and
ask them if they are in trouble and if
they are having domestic violence issues
to call the police
he also stresses there were no prior
calls for help from this couple we do
want to remind you if you need help
anytime it is available to you and we do
have a list of resources attached to
this article on our website the officer
involved in the shooting is on paid
administrative leave tonight if gallarzo
had survived the shooting he would have
been charged with murder among other
charges we're live outside metro
headquarters i'm david charns live local
now